elles prennent la passerelle mais elle
est glissante elles sont pas du tout
rassurées ah elles sont
oh non allez
on m'appelle la bergère santé parce que
je n'ai pas été je suis l'herbe ça veut
dire que quand il y a plus d'herbe je
l'ai plus loin je vais là où il y en a
un peu comme les oiseaux
itinérant qui va
d'un village à l'autre c'est un troupeau
qui ne mange uniquement dehors
elle mange que ce qu'elle trouve toute
l'année et je lève les agneaux que je
vends après en direct je reviens au même
endroit que tous les six mois voire une
fois par an parce que parce que comme ça
elles ont toujours de leur propre devant
elle elles aiment vraiment ça
et après l'autre critère c'est la
diversité tu vois tu en as plein à en
bordure là qui qui préfère manger en
bordure que des que des herbes grâce là
dans la prairie et ça c'est pour c'est
pour leur santé j'imagine
dans la forêt elles sont plus inquiète
aussi parce qu'elles se voyent pas tout
à l'heure elle bouge elle bouge beaucoup
plus
que sur un prêt
sauf s'il y a vraiment beaucoup à manger
mais cette année il y a pas beaucoup à
manger dans la forêt je sais pas si
c'est à cause de la sécheresse ou de la
tempête ça fait 15 ans que je fais ça
presque la plupart des terrains que j'ai
eu c'est les gens qui sont venus me voir
pour me demander si je voulais mettre
mes brebis chez eux pour ceux qui revoit
leur terrain ça leur économise à zéro
voyage par an au minimum je fais manger
avec mes brebis l'herbe qui en hiver
soit gel soit pourri et du coup ça leur
ça leur refait une une pousse-propre
pour les fins de l'année de l'année
prochaine et voilà et il y en a qui ont
simplement le plaisir d'avoir les brebis
une petite semaine chez eux allez allez
allez allez allez
maintenant je voulais petit à petit les
ramener dans le dans les prairies comme
dans la forêt il y a pas tellement à
manger là ils ont trouvé un coin qui est
quand même pas trop mal du coup bon on
reste un petit peu plus c'est
principalement de lire quand il trouve
du lierre là et elle se pose un peu
hier un petit peu de ronce peut-être
les regardez manger en fait c'est
quelque chose de Noël apaisant c'est
contemplative c'est c'est faire sans
rien faire au bout d'un moment tu as un
espèce de sentiment de
liens avec les brebis la nature tu vois
ça te donne un petit goût d'éternité
normalement
au bout d'un moment tout le monde devait
se poser couché
[Applaudissements]
si tout va bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non je peux m'en aller je peux m'en
aller maintenant elles sont elles sont
dedans je peux m'en aller et après
j'aime bien regarder c'est un peu mon
QG pour avoir un peu tout sur place
parce que je passe quand même beaucoup
de temps avec mes brebis en été je reste
souvent endormie en hiver un peu moins
mais ça m'arrive aussi
oui je suis un peu fière de
d'avoir réussi à implanter un troupeau
comme ça qu'elle soit bien en forme sans
jamais manger autre chose que ce qu'elle
trouve dehors oui c'est c'est pas mal
satisfaisant c'est satisfaisant aussi
d'avoir pu faire partie de ce pays il a
la double c'est un bon
c'est une belle vie
[Musique]